hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 3 video it was
called the last lap obviously all about
the Joker so just careful for spoilers
as we get into it because there's a lot
a lot of big stuff that happened in this
episode I'm gonna explain that last big
twist first because Bruno Heller the the
showrunner was kind of explaining how
they're treating the Joker character
like what was what was going on when
they ended the episode Jerome is dead
what does that mean about the legacy of
the Joker on Gotham at least on the TV
show he said they're trying to honor the
legacy of the Joker in the comics so
it's not really just like any one
specific event like someone getting
dumped in a vat of chemicals that gives
rise to this really iconic character and
Roman the Maineiacs actions inspire
something of like a cult of personality
so more and more people are inspired to
act like this so eventually the Joker
will rise out of this group of people
not any of those specific individuals
that they showed at the end of the
episode like it's not like they're
trying to tease like one of these people
will actually become the Joker just the
people all over the city saw this and it
inspired them in a really bad way so the
scenes are just being laid for the
actual Joker it's the same thing with
black mastic and Richard C Otis you know
until Roman sea onus comes along no
actual black mask but I thought they did
a really great job with the metaphor
that they're trying to prove and there
were some great comic book moments in
the episode so let's just dig into a
little bit top 5 WTF moments number 5
Gordon is on the warpath so I love the
way they opened with the guy flying out
the window then he told the other guy to
spread the word threw him out the window
too this is the kind of energy you're
gonna see from Michael Chiklis whenever
he shows up next week he's gonna be the
new captain
remember Essen was promoted but they
technically didn't name a new police
chief then she died so there's still
like this vacuum to be filled I feel
like this is really good setup for a
Gordon arc just because Ben McKenzie
does a lot better when he's busting
heads than when he's trying to tell
jokes or be funny it just works better
if he gets to be the serious character
and everyone else gets to be ridiculous
Gordon himself you know from the comics
the movies all the different port rails
are at least the best port rails has a
sense of humor but he is never the
actual funny person in any given scene
it's using somebody else that tells the
jokes and he's the one that reacts to
them so definitely big thumbs up for
hardcore Gordon speaking of badasses on
at number four Alfred is a total badass
former Royal Marine who is also still
something of a ladies man remember he's
a butler not a monk so he wouldn't be
too surprised if Sean Pertwee at some
point got a little play on the show I
was a little curious how long they were
let that whole thing with Leslie go on
like clearly she is just like okay I'm
not sure what to do here this you know
older man is hitting on me he seems very
charming but I don't wanna be mean even
the last moment they had together were
they getting ready to walk off and
Gordon just stares at him like did you
just you just hit on my girlfriend what
I don't I don't know what to do with
that however it kind of takes it back a
little bit when he's walking away with
Bruce like I can't believe you let me go
on like that so so you know like that
it's not gonna continue to be a thing it
was funny in this one episode if they
would have continued to do that it would
have gotten really creepy go Leslie
Thompkins and Bruce we got to talk about
that so number three Leslie Thompkins
finally meets Bruce Wayne now they
changed a little bit from the comics
here just because of the legacy of
Leslie Thompkins clinic Park Row in the
transition to Crime Alley in the place
where Bruce's parents originally died in
the comics so if you watched Batman in
the animated series you're probably
pretty familiar with the Leslie
Thompkins character that's actually like
very very true to the original Bruce
Wayne Leslie Thompkins story in the
comics she owned a place on Park Row
this really nice street in Gotham then
slowly over time things in the city got
so bad that they started calling Park
Row Crime Alley Park row turned into
crime alley but she still lived there so
that's where her clinic was it's in
Crime Alley that's near where Bruce
Wayne's parents ended up getting killed
so in the animated series where you know
you see him laying down roses with
Leslie Thompkins and being really sad
that's near where her clinic is she got
a lot of the story that they're giving
to Gordon now like Gordon is kind of
like this surrogate father to Bruce
Wayne you know like this authority
figure in the comics that was Leslie
Thompkins he was kind of like a mother
figure to him but the TV show just you
know changing a few minor things about
the backstory most of her history in the
comics is her working with
underprivileged children providing them
with medical care so they they just they
might have her working more with the
Children's Hospital on the show they
didn't really have much of a scene in
this episode but it could be fun to see
them again so if they want to have more
Bruce Leslie scenes that they would do
it in that context on the number two
Theo and Jerome put on a show for the
city they kind of buried the lead a
little bit but this was all about Theo
positioning himself as a savior of the
city using Jerome to do that mostly they
they were just putting this forward as
drum just terrorizing people so if you
were really surprised when Theo stepped
out on camera and went in like he
actually turned the camera and said my
name is theo galavan where you know
we're not going to stand for this
that's why it's because they wanted that
to be a surprise Jerome and Barbara were
fun if not a little bit silly but you
can understand why they kind of brushed
over a lot of that like they didn't want
you to take it too seriously because of
the twist ending I like the way they're
setting up James Frank's character
though he is actually getting some great
character development he's a billionaire
we don't know where his money came from
we just know that his family built
Gotham or was one of the families to
build Gotham which gets into court of
Alice territory when he talked about
their name being etched on every bridge
like every building in the city that's
actually a literal thing in the court of
Alice traces of the court are actually
etched in all the biggest foundations of
Gotham all over the city going all the
way back to the person that started the
Wayne dynasty so obviously the Wayne's
just being one family that was part of
the court of Alice there gonna be a lot
of other big rich families so Theo could
be from any of those they could they
could make him anybody they want it
seems like he's an original creation of
the show right now
although tigress is not Tigers is
straight out of the comics as is Barbara
Kean although they haven't really dealt
with the history of Barbara's family
technically if she's super-rich then her
family would have ties as the court of
owls to that doesn't really seem like
that's the direction they're taking
Barbara she seems like she's really just
like freeing the crazy but of course out
of my number one WTF moment theo kills
jerome to prove to the city on camera
that he is a savior sorry bro this is
not part of the plan and if there was
any doubt they'd show him on the slab
there in the coroner's office with the
smile on his face so very clearly jerome
is not the Joker that we know from the
comics but his actions on live camera
inspire people all over the city to just
free the crazy just like Barbara is
doing right now and like I said I don't
think we're gonna see the actual Joker
anytime soon that's why they showed you
like a little kid laughing a really old
man laughing at a bar a bunch of random
criminals on the street laughing they
just they wanted to be really ambiguous
there's actually this really awesome
Shakespeare quote from one of his plays
called the Christmas prince from way way
back in the 1600s laughinn laughinn my
friend he laughs a--the best that laughs
ahthe to the end that's where that's
saying having the last laugh comes from
it's all about temporary victories like
you may be laughing now but I'll be
laughing last like the person that gets
the last laugh is actually the one that
wins so the title of the episode
was called the last lap Jerome kind of
got the last laugh he's inspiring a city
full of Joker type people to rise up
despite the fact that he was betrayed by
Theo speaking of which I just I wanted
to add that little bit about Barbara's
betrayal with Theo against tabatha
against tigress she seems like she's
trying to create some chaos between the
two of them so she'll have her own angle
on all this which I actually kind of
like it would be nice to see her get her
own arc so let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think about the way they
treated the Jerome Joker character do
you like the vague way that they're
treating his legacy and what do you
think about like some of the other
storylines I did peppered the penguin in
there but it felt like it was just
tacked on he really didn't need to be in
this episode at all but I think they
were just setting him up for next week
because next week's a big penguin
episode there was also that really
sentimental moment with Bruce and selina
Hey I miss you I miss us going around
having fun jumping around rooftops
that'll probably happen again this
season she's working with the penguin
right now Catwoman is one of the few
truly neutral characters she can do good
things she can help Bruce at the same
time that she works for the penguin
who's gonna be more of a lawful evil
character I feel like Gotham is actually
done a really great job this season so
far of enhancing their sense of style
their sense of narrative progression and
complexity it's a lot more fun to follow
along speaking of which don't forget the
flash actually comes back tomorrow arrow
comes back on Wednesday and I'm actually
I'm looking for a new Thursday show
there are a couple animated shows that
I'm trying to pick out I'm just really
sad that Legend of Korra isn't on
anymore
book four just started airing in October
last year so I'm looking like Steven
universe or Adventure Time just a new
cartoon animated series to do videos for
us I miss having fun it was a lot of fun
doing animated series so if you have any
requests or any suggestions just leave
them in the comments be sure to
subscribe to get everything
and I've got a couple other bonus videos
that I'm working I'll try to get that up
between now and Wednesday like we just
have agents of shield and I have a game
Thrones bonus video so I'll try to
finish all those videos as fast as
possible just in case you guys didn't
see it I posted a flash episode 1
trailer video this morning you can click
here to watch that it's got all kinds of
firestorm and rogues all kinds awesome
stuff and you can click here to watch
all my Gotham videos if you haven't
caught up yet thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you